[Applaus]
[Musik]
spanien ist ein land mit der
zweifelhaften ehre bei der
jugendarbeitslosigkeit weltweit an der
spitze steht ja du hast richtig gehört
unglaubliche 40 prozent der junge
spanier sind arbeitslos die einzigen
geländer die spanien in dieser hinsicht
übertreffen sind völlig desolate staaten
wie armenien südafrika oder der gaza
streifen und wie du dir vorstellen
kannst haben sie es hier mit alles
andere als einem trivialen problem zu
tun für spanien stellt ist eines der
grössten langfrist probleme überhaupt da
wir reden hier nicht nur über
arbeitslosigkeit überleg mal vier von
zehn menschen unter 25 jahren in spanien
haben keinen job das bedeutet armut
frustration sozialen abstieg der verlust
von qualifikation und selbstwertgefühl
und dadurch natürlich viel viel
ungerechtigkeit ja in diesem video
werden wir über ungleichheit aus einer
perspektive sprechen die euch
wahrscheinlich schockieren wird
[Musik]
es mag überraschend klingen aber spanien
ist das land mit der drittgrößten kluft
zwischen arm und reich in europa nur die
vom kommunismus verwüsteten länder
rumänien und bulgarien können in dieser
unrühmlichen disziplinen mit der
einstigen weltmacht spanien mithalten
schwer zu glauben nicht wahr sein
eigentlicher spanier einen großen und
großzügigen sozialstaat es ist zb ein
land das die ungleichheit zwischen den
geschlechtern so ernst nimmt dass er
sogar ein eigenes ministerium für
gleichstellung eingerichtet hat das
heißt es gibt ein ganzes ministerium das
nicht mit der beseitigung von
ungleichheiten zwischen männern und
frauen beschäftigt tatsächlich ist
gender gerechtigkeit auch ein
lieblingsthema der spanischen medien
welche der entsprechenden erziehung
ihrer konsumenten gerne viel raum
einräumen was wir uns jedoch
vergegenwärtigen müssen ist das ein
medial erzeugt das bild nicht unbedingt
viel mit der realität zu tun haben muss
dies zeigt sich auch in diesem fall denn
tatsächlich sind 26 prozent der
spanischen frauen von armut bedroht
während es bei männern 24,6 prozent sind
wir haben ist also mit einem unterschied
zwischen den geschlechtern von sage und
schreibe 1,4 prozent zu tun das ist
schon eine zum himmel schreiende
ungerechtigkeit für deren beseitigung
des land unbedingt eine eigene
milliardenschwere ministerialbürokratie
benötigt aber weiter ernst betrachten
wir doch mal die ungerechtigkeit
zwischen den menschen nach einem anderen
kriterium dem alter
[Musik]
in diesem fall sind 30 3 prozent der
spanischen kinder und jugendlichen unter
18 jahren von armut bedroht verglichen
mit 14,7 prozent der über 65-jährigen
mit anderen worten das wahre problem in
spanien ist nicht die ungleichheit zu
stehen geschlechter sondern die zwischen
den altersgruppen und glauben wir reden
hier nicht über irgendein problem wir
reden über das problem die zukunft der
nation ein wahrer elefant im raum über
den kaum jemand zu sprechen wagt denn es
ist ja viel bequemer probleme zu lösen
die es nicht wirklich gibt
das gemälde das du hier siehst heißt
saturn verschlägt seinen sohn von
francisco de goya du machst ist als ein
eher unangenehmes bild empfinden aber
anhand der daten könnte man sagen dass
spaniens politisches system ein riesiger
saturn ist der seine jugend verschlingt
um ein netzwerk von besitzstandswahrer
zu ernähren mit anderen worten der ware
konflikt in spanien ist nicht madrid
gegen katalonien auch nicht männer gegen
frauen der baarer konflikt in spanien
besteht zwischen den in den 60er jahren
geborenen den spanischen buhmann und
denen seiner internet achtziger jahren
geborenen den millennials und sumann und
ich weiß was viele von euch sagen werden
mag was du dir das ganze nicht ein wenig
zu einfach was ist mit all der
altersarmut sind für diese miese
einkommenssituation der jungen spanier
wirklich die alten verantwortlich bist
du uns wirklich erzählen dass spanien
ein gerechtes land für junge leute ist
und die burma die armen millennials
unterdrücken und ausbeuten nun keine
angst heute werden wir diese komplexen
und oft widersprüchlichen fragen restlos
klären und daraus sicher auch viel
lernen was ich auf andere länder und
gesellschaften übertragen lässt und wie
so oft wollen wir dies zunächst mit
einem schnellen blick in die geschichte
tun
[Musik]
ok
es gibt in spanien ein phänomen das sich
immer stärker durch die so genannten
minis das sind mehr oder weniger junge
menschen die weder studieren noch
arbeiten es kommt immer häufiger vor der
spanier bei ihren eltern wohnen bis sie
30 oder noch älter sind vielleicht geht
er selbst junge leute aus spanien welche
sich in dieser situation befinden nun
dieser zustand geht nicht nur den eltern
der linie es häufig auf die nerven
sondern auch den statistikern denn wenn
diese das einkommen der millennials mit
dem der boomer vergleichen wollen um
festzustellen welche altersgruppe denn
nun schlechter dran ist haben sie
aufgrund dieser ganzen gemengelage ein
veritables chaos vor sich das zu
entwirren unmöglich erscheint denkt mal
darüber nach um ein sozial und
volkswirtschaftlich aussagekräftiges
bild zu erhalten das einkommen
normalerweise in bezug zu haushalten
gemessen nicht zu einzelpersonen und die
meisten millennials die über kein
eigenes einkommen verfügen leben nun mal
bei ihren eltern die einen job haben wie
kommt man aus dieser statistischen koks
wieder heraus nun das wiso hartwig team
hat eine eigene chef methode ausprobiert
die auf den durchschnittsgehalt nach
alte und arbeitslosenquote basiert
schaut euch einfach mal die folgende
grafik an
[Musik]
du siehst bei denen die über 60-jährigen
im durchschnitt fast dreimal so viel wie
die unter 25-jährigen aber wie gesagt
handelt es sich nur um eine nehrung
höchstwahrscheinlich ist die
ungleichheit noch viel größer weil wir
auch andere einkommensströme wie aktien
dividenden oder mieteinnahmen mit
einbeziehen müssten um die eine
vorstellung davon zu geben menschen über
65 jahre haben ein vermögen das bis zu
fünf mal größer ist als das von 35
jährigen wir reden hier über dasselbe
maß an ungleichheit die wir es zum
beispiel in den usa verwenden ganz genau
in den usa dem hort des
raubtierkapitalismus der für seine große
kluft zwischen arm und reich bekannt ist
und wenn es um die kluft zwischen den
generationen geht hat spanien ein
ähnliches problem wie die vereinigten
staaten oder sogar ein noch weitaus
schlimmeres
[Musik]
lotte wir sprechen über ein europäisches
land dessen politische landschaft
gegenüber der amerikanischen eigentlich
wie die brutstätte des sozialismus merkt
um es klar zu sagen ein teil der
ungleichheit im land der stars and
straps ist auf die große zahl von
milliardären zurückzuführen die jeden
durchschnitt verzehren der fall spaniens
liegt da ganz anders in diesem fall
können wir eindeutig von den
auserwählten sprechen die alle
privilegien eines auf ihre bedürfnisse
zugeschnitten des systems genießen und
von den außenseitern die darunter zu
leiden haben und wer sind diese
auserwählten nun eindeutig diejenigen
die über 60 jahre alt sind
[Applaus]
das heißt diejenigen die in den 60er
jahren geboren wurden die 60er jahre
waren die baby buben jahre in spanien
wir sprechen hier von der größten
generation auf der iberischen halbinsel
viele von ihnen sind rentner andere sind
beamte und wieder andere arbeiten im
sogenannten sektor der giganten was wir
darunter verstehen und wir sprechen von
den größten konzernen spaniens welche
sich die wirtschaft des landes
untereinander aufgeteilt haben zu dieser
kategorie gehören alle wichtigen
energieunternehmen die wichtigsten
banken und unternehmen wie telefonica
diese unternehmen beschäftigen mehr als
eine halbe million menschen und viele
ihre altgedienten arbeitnehmer genießen
ganz besondere privilegien privilegien
den nicht nur unverschämt wirken sondern
geradezu parasitär und gesellschaft
schädlich wollt ihr wissen wie diese
aussehen dann passt mal auf
[Musik]
geld fürs nichtstun
die meisten von euch werden schon mal
vom telefonica konzern gehört haben dem
eigentümer der bekannten marke o2 wir
sprechen von einem internationalen
telekommunikations riesen was du
vielleicht nicht weißt ist das ist eine
zeit gab in der telefonica ein
staatliches unternehmen war ja so wie zb
1 die deutsche telekom telefonica waren
es 1997 im besitz des spanischen staates
in diesem jahr privatisierte spanien das
unternehmen nur wenige monate nachdem
deutschland seinen einstigen telefon
monopolisten und die börse brachte und
wie du dir vorstellen kannst haben sich
die gewerkschaften massiv gegen die
privatisierung gewährt also musste die
regierung eine sehr großzügige
vereinbarung mit ihnen treffen vor allem
was arbeitsplatzgarantien angeht und
trotzdem hat es telefonica geschafft
seine belegschaft im laufe der jahre
gewaltig zu reduzieren um die eine
vorstellung davon zu geben 2016
beschäftigte telefonica in sein spanisch
niederlassungen noch 33.000 400
mitarbeiter und vier jahre später im
jahr 2020 hatte seine belegschaft auf
22.900 mitarbeiter reduziert jetzt
denkst du wahrscheinlich dass dies
schlechte nachrichten für die
arbeitnehmer von telefonica sind oder
gestiegener leistungsdruck mehr
überstunden die verbliebenen mitarbeiter
müssten die doppelte arbeit erledigen
nun nicht ganz schoss den ball an
telefonica schickt ihrer mitarbeiter mit
53 jahren und 70 prozent gehalt nach
hause diese nachricht ist aus dem jahr
2009 10 in diesem fall hat telefonica
mehr als 2600 beschäftigte entlassen
allerdings mit einem goldenen handschlag
wenn du mehr als 15 jahre im unternehmen
gearbeitet hat und über 53 jahre alt
bist bekommst du 68 prozent eines
gehalts und zwar bis 65 wenn die
rentenkassen übernimmt ihr sprechen hier
von durchschnittlich 1500 euro pro monat
die du einfach so bekommst du egal was
du tust mit anderen worten du könntest
dir einen anderen job suchen oder ein
eigenes unternehmen gründen und
weiterhin diese telefonica rente
erhalten aber warte ein moment denn das
ist kein einzelfall gerade zum zeitpunkt
der erstellung dieses videos hatten
energy eines der größten
energieunternehmen spaniens eine weitere
personalanpassungen vorgenommen in
diesem fall sind sie dazu übergegangen
einigen beschäftigten bis zu sechs
jahres gehälter zu zahlen ich weiß nicht
ob der klar ist mit welchen zahlen wir
es hier zu tun haben also ich gehe ja
ein kleines beispiel stellte eine person
vor die beiden energy arbeitet und
55.000 euro verdient pro jahr das ist
ein ziemlich typisches gehalt für das
mittlere management nun wenn du das
unternehmen lässt kannst du eine
abfindung von bis zu 340.000 euro
mitnehmen und wem hast du das zu
verdanken tragen die chefs dieser
konzerne alle spendierhosen oder was
nein ganz und gar nicht das alles ist
zum größten teil das ergebnis
jahrelanger machtkämpfe mit den
gewerkschaften um freie hand bei der
optimierung ihrer unter dem zu bekommen
und nicht durch arbeitskämpfe dabei
gestürzt zu werden haben sich die
konzerne gegenüber ihrer belegschaft zu
all diesen vereinbarungen verpflichtet
und ich weiß ganz genau was viele von
euch an dieser stelle denken wohl lieber
mag liegt da bitteschön das problem
früher oder später werden all diese
unternehmen die arbeitslosen millennials
doch einstellen müssen oder nun das
problem ist ganz einfach dass sie es
nicht tun und wieso da hier kommen wir
zum nächsten aktuell in unserer
geschichte den beratungsunternehmen und
zeitarbeitsfirmen
[Musik]
stell dir vor du bist ein manager bei
telefonica und bräuchte es für den
bereich dringend neue mitarbeiter ein
problem ist jetzt jedoch dass auch für
diese mitarbeiter die großzügigen
gewerkschafts vereinbarungen gelten
würden jede neueinstellung würde für die
firma ein zu großes risiko darstellen
welche am ende hunderttausende von euro
an mehrkosten zusätzlich bedeuten solle
aber siehe da es gibt doch eine
billigere lösung
beratungsunternehmen und
zeitarbeitsfirmen mit anderen worten
warum sollte man arbeitnehmer direkt
einstellen und sich damit ein
unkalkulierbares kostenrisiko ans bein
binden wenn man stattdessen einen bequem
und ohne mehrkosten kündbaren vertrag
mit einem subunternehmen schließen kann
dass der die notwendige arbeitskraft auf
abruf zur verfügung stellt nicht mehr
und nicht weniger dieses unternehmen hat
keine vereinbarung mit einer
gewerkschaft unterzeichnet es kann also
leute einstellen und entlassen ohne
millionenschwere abfindungen zahlen zu
müssen das ergebnis sind konzerne in
denen quasi nur noch die manager fest
angestellt und von den gewerkschaften
erkämpfte vereinbarungen abgesichert
sind und die masse an
leistungserbringern sind nichts als
feier in fire kräfte mit anderen worten
wenn du in einem beliebigen tag in ein
telefonica führung gehst wirst du dort
viele junge menschen arbeiten sehen aber
rechtlich gesehen ist der arbeitgeber
dieser menschen nicht infoniqa sondern
ein viel kleineres unternehmen das alles
erklärt die folgte grafen
[Musik]
was du hier siehst ist der prozentsatz
der zeitarbeitnehmer in spanien im
vergleich zum rest der europäischen
union wie du sehen kannst ist der
unterschied eklatant dem restlichen
europa sind befristete verträge eine
anomalie die meisten menschen dort haben
ein festes arbeitsverhältnis auf
unbestimmte zeit in spanien jedoch sind
befristete verträge für fast alle unter
35 den namen und das problem ist
natürlich nicht nur die mangelnde
arbeitsplatzsicherheit sondern die
allgemein schlechteren konditionen
dieser verträgen vom preisniveau über
urlaubsansprüche bis zur
altersversorgung sie sind natürlich in
allen punkten schlechter als bei den
alteingesessenen festangestellten denn
deren üppige privilegien müssen ja von
irgendjemandem bezahlt sprich erarbeitet
werden und dieser jemand sind ganz
bestimmt nicht die aktionäre der
unternehmen darauf kannst du gift nehmen
so und nun kommen wir zum eigentlichen
preis frage dieses videos wählen man
dieses problem eigentlich wirklich lösen
was wäre wenn ich dir verraten würde
dass diese ungleichheit so gewollt ist
und zwar von allen akteuren die daran
wirklich etwas ändern könnten tja jetzt
kommen wir es wie einem teil unseres
heutigen videos der sich bis auf die
knochen schocken wird
die wirtschaftliche reservisten armee
im jahr 2010 unterzeichnet sei eine
gruppe von 100 spanischen
wirtschaftswissenschaftlers sogenannte
manifest der 100 neben vielen anderen
dingen schlugen sie zwei maßnahmen vor
um der zeitarbeiter ein ende zu setzen
den einheitsvertrag und in sogenannten
österreichischen rucksack worin
bestanden diese maßnahmen nun der
sogenannte einheitsvertrag sieht vor
dass alle arbeitnehmer die gleichen
rechte und den gleichen schutz haben
würden mit anderen worten statt
festangestellte auf der einen und
zeitarbeitskräfte auf der anderen seite
zu haben würden alle fest angestellt
seien und was ist mit dem
österreichischen rucksack gemeint dieser
soll versinnbildlichen dass der
arbeitnehmer statt einer abfindung im
fall der kündigung jeden monat punkte
auf eine art sparkonto ansammelt auf
diese weise will wirst du selbst wenn
das unternehmen dich nicht entlässt und
austria ein stücken geht die abfindung
nicht verlieren weil logischerweise
immer noch über die angesammelten
ersparnisse auf diesen punktekonto
verfügen würdest
und ich weiß was du jetzt denkst dieser
vorschlag scheint einer jener
klassischen gewerkschafts vorschläge zu
sein welche linke toll finden und von
den arbeitgebern scharf kritisiert
werden nun hier kommt die eigentliche
überraschung ja die spanische politik
markt stark polarisiert seien und oft
scheint ist ihr schier unmöglich einen
konsens zu finden im jahr 2012 konnten
sich jedoch sowohl die linke als auch
die rechte schnell einigen sie alle
sagten entschieden nein so
einheitsvertrag
regierung arbeitgeber und gewerkschaften
lehnen die umsetzung des einheits
vertrages ab und wenn du dich fragst
warum alle diese akteure ein problem mit
ihm hatten und warum niemand von ihnen
will dass alle arbeitnehmer die gleichen
bedingungen haben können wir die nur
eine antwort geben der diese grafik an
die zahlen sprechen für sich
diese grafik zeigt die unterschiede in
der arbeitslosigkeit zwischen duman und
melanie ist die rote linie steht für die
unter 25 jährigen die blaue linie steht
für die über 55-jährigen wie du siehst
haben die buga viel weniger unter der
krise gelitten als die millennials und
so mast mit anderen worten so lange es
menschen mit befristeten verträgen gibt
die entlassen werden können können die
blume egal ob sie auf der arbeitnehmer
oder arbeitgeber seite stehen in ihren
machtpositionen und besorgte leute
entlassen und die dividende dafür
einstreichen
stell dir folgendes vor du bist ein
manager bei telefonica und bekommt den
auftrag personal abzubauen um die kosten
zu senken und den aktienkurs in die höhe
zu treiben rund 2000 beschäftigte sollen
gehen wie würdest du vorgehen nun wenn
sie alle die gleiche art von
arbeitsvertrag hätten würdest du
versuchen die weniger produktiven leute
zu entlassen nicht wahr bei der
derzeitigen gesetzeslage könnte uns die
entlassung eines beamers jedoch 200.000
euro kosten während die entlastung eines
millennials praktisch umsonst ist die
schlussfolgerung bevor wir einen humor
feuern feuerwehr liebe einen melanie
denn lässt da müsste schon verdammt viel
produktiver seien
200.000 euro produktiver damit es sich
lohnt ihn im unternehmen zu behalten es
ist so als würde auf den jungen
mitarbeitern eine gewaltige last liegen
welche sie bei der bewertung ihrer
produktivität extrem diskriminiert die
messlatte für sie liegt eben um jene
200.000 euro höher als für einen älteren
kollegen mit langfrist vertrag und die
firma lohnte sich mehr einen älteren
aber und produktiven mitarbeiter zu
behalten als einen ionen und produktiven
und jetzt eskaliert das mal auf alle
unternehmen und die ganze wirtschaft
hoch und du wirst verstehen auf welche
weise diese regelung zur verzerrung des
wettbewerbs führt nicht nur unter den
arbeitnehmern sondern auch zwischen
unternehmen aus spanien und den aus
anderen ländern und letztendlich der
gesamten spanischen volkswirtschaft denn
dort zählt nicht leistung sondern nur
status und dieser ist daran gebunden die
altmann ist und wann man seinen
arbeitsvertrag bekommen hat was meinst
du wie gut kann sich eine solche
volkswirtschaft gegen eine andere
behaupten welche den emanzipations und
qualifikationschancen ihrer jungen
menschen keinen derartigen klotz ans
bein bindet und ich weiß was du jetzt
denkst das alles kann doch nicht pure
absicht sein will bis waldpolitik
wirklich sagen dass das gesamte
politische system spaniens darauf
ausgerichtet ist die jungen zu gunsten
der über 50-jährigen systematisch zu
diskriminieren ihre zukunftschancen und
damit die des ganzen landes zu ersticken
nur damit ist die älteren bequemer haben
nun die wahrheit ist dass das was du
gerade gesehen hast nur der anfang ist
hast du schon mal was von der
umverteilung des reichtums gehört
glaubst du wirklich dass in spanien
diejenigen die mehr haben auch mehr
zahlen sich irgendwie proportional an
der finanzierung der grundlagen der
gesellschaft beteiligen dann höre ich
lieber mal gut zu
[Musik]
faktoren verschlingt seine kinder
ich werde mal ein anschauliches beispiel
geben welches auch eine starke
symbolkraft gesetze halte ich lieber
fest denn wir werden jetzt über windeln
sprechen ja genau diese weichen
schutzhüllen für kleine und große
scheinen nun in spanien kostet eine
packung mit etwa 90 babywindeln etwa 14
euro in diesem preis ist die
mehrwertsteuer in höhe von 21 prozent
enthalten aber wie du weißt benutzen
nicht nur babys wendel viele ältere
menschen leiden an inkontinenz und
brauchen ebenso windel das sind
natürlich etwas größerer modelle
sogenannte erwachsenen windeln was
würdest du sagen wie viel eine packung
windeln für erwachsene in spanien kostet
10 euro 10 euro nun die antwort lautet
null euro denn für die spanischen
rentnern übernimmt einfach der staat die
gesamten kosten für windeln nun könntest
du vielleicht einwenden kommen schon mal
inkontinenz im alter ist schon eine
unangenehme sache wieso sollte die
gesellschaft den davon betroffenen
menschen dann nicht wenigstens
finanziell unter die arme greifen klar
das ist ein argument aber wäre es dann
nicht gerecht wenn man auch junge
familien entlasten würde all jene
menschen die sowieso schon auf grund
unsicherer arbeitsplätzen oder gar
arbeitslosigkeit eine schwere last zu
tragen haben wen wundert es da dass die
jungen spanier einfach keine kinder mehr
bekommen wollen und das land einen der
katastrophalsten demokratien der welt
aufweist zukunft fehlanzeige und glaubt
mir dieses windel beispiel ist ganz und
gar kein einzelfall sondern steht für
das gesamte bescheidenes system denn was
bei windeln an zusätzlich zum beispiel
im steuersystem gleitend fort was weißt
du wer sollte eigentlich die geringsten
steuern bezahlen gerechterweise wohl
derjenige der auch am wenigsten geld
verdient oder nun dann schau dir mal
diese grafik an
[Musik]
du kannst die augen reiben so viel du
willst das ernste fünftel der spanier
hat eine höhere steuerbelastung als die
anderen beiden kritik tatsächlich
beträgt der unterschied zwischen den
steuern die das ärmste quintil um das
reichste greenpeace hat nur zehn prozent
die erklärung liegt nämlich in
belastungen die der mehrwertsteuer oder
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen und ja das
ärmste fünftel ist auch ganz zufällig
das jüngste fünftel die zahnräder des
spanischen schweines systems fallen so
perfekt ineinander inzwischen sind viele
von euch wahrscheinlich wirklich empört
aber spart euch bitte noch etwas davon
auf wir sind noch nicht fertig denn die
frage ist nicht nur wie viel geld an
steuern von wem bezahlt wird sondern
auch wie diese steuermittel dann
verwendet werden wohin fließt das ganze
geld nun ich würde die an dieser stelle
liebend gerne sagen dass die mit den
straßen schulen und krankenhäuser
fließen aber der realität ist leider
dass der größte ausgabenposten des
spanischen staates welcher ist nah viele
von euch werden es schon erraten haben
die renten um die eine vorstellung davon
zu geben rentenzahlungen machen 36
prozent aller öffentlichen haushalte für
das jahr 2021 aus und ich weiß was viele
von euch denken wir hätten das größte
problem der gesamten westlichen welt wie
ihr wisst haben spanien und viele andere
europäische länder ein riesenproblem mit
der rentenlücke und diese wird immer
bedrohlicher aber in spanien kommt noch
eine ganz besondere spezialität hinzu
schau dir mal diese grafik an
[Musik]
hier kannst du sehen dass spanien eines
der großzügigsten rentensysteme hat und
zwar weltweit er in großbritannien zum
beispiel erhält ein rentenalter
durchschnittlich 24 prozent der
gesamtsumme die er während seines
gesamten berufslebens verdient hat das
heißt drei viertel des gesamten lebens
einkommens bekommt ein dritter ist halt
und ein viertel danach als rente in
deutschland ist dieses verhältnis etwa
eins zu eins das heißt 50 prozent
fließen als gehalt die anderen 50
prozent als rente und jetzt haltet euch
fest in spanien sind es sage und
schreibe
83 prozent mit anderen worten wenn du
und das 25 jahre alt bist musst du in
spanien monat für monat mit 750 euro
einkommen über die runden kommen wenn du
dich aber im ruhestand befindet bekommst
du im schnitt 1200 euro im monat genießt
obendrein jedoch alle wirklichen
sozialleistungen steuervorteile und
natürlich stehen dir auch deine ganzen
ersparnisse zur verfügung die im laufe
des lebens bilden konnte ist etwas
worauf die junge generation nicht mal in
ihren wildesten träumen hoffen kann das
heißt der sozialstaat trägt kaum dazu
bei die bestehende kluft zwischen arm
und reich zu verringern also zwischen
buhmann und melanie ist erst mal einen
blick auf diese grafik
wie du sieht spielt in irland das für
niedrige steuern bekannt ist der staat
die aktivste rolle bei der
armutsbekämpfung und am anderen ende des
rankings finden wir spanien vor das zu
jenen vier staaten gehört welche am
wenigsten effektiv gegen die armut
vorgehen das perfide an der geschichte
ist auch noch dass in spanien praktisch
alle politiker ein kartell gebildet
haben und den gleichen weg einschlagen
die regierung erhöht die renten um 0,9
prozent die ministranten um 1,8 prozent
bis 2021 das wird fast 1,5 milliarden
euro kosten casado verlangt dass die
gehälter eingefroren werden und warnt
die renten werden nicht angetastet und
die konsequenz aus diesen bald
nachrichten ist folgende die regierung
erhöht die abgabenquote für selbständige
um bis zu 24 euro pro kopf inmitten
einer einbrechenden wirtschaft genau wie
politiker in spanien erhöhen die steuern
und abgaben diese steuer erhöhungen
betreffen vor allem die unteren
einkommen also wie millennials und all
das geld fließt in die taschen der
spitzenverdiener also der boomer
[Musik]
das ganze ist also der perfekte
teufelskreis eine catch 22 situation
eine abwärtsspirale aus der es kein
entrinnen gibt denn auch sicht der
partikularinteressen der politiker macht
es vollkommen sinn die ungleichheit und
ungerechtigkeit im land noch anzuheizen
auch für die zukunft des landes dabei
verfrühstückt wird denkt mal darüber
nach die puma sind die größte
wählergruppe des ganzen landes die über
50-jährigen machen 40 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung aus und sie haben eine
höhere wahlbeteiligung als die
frustrierten jungen menschen mit anderen
worten sie sind genau jede wählergruppe
die kein politiker ärgern will fast alle
politischen kampagnen sind auf sie
ausgerichtet und wir reden hier nicht
nur über politische kampagne auch
konsumgüterunternehmen sind auf sie
aufmerksam geworden wenn du also in
spanien lebst hast du dich darauf
einstellen viele anzeigen zu sehen die
sich an diese gruppe richten senioren
sind die wahren konsumenten der zukunft
wie du siehst ist für den absturz
spaniens in die hölle der ungleichheit
und perspektivlosigkeit also gar keine
große verschwörung notwendig er ist das
ganz natürliche ergebnis einer kaputten
demographie etwas was die meisten
entwickelten länder erwartet aber jetzt
ist die frage erst mal an dich gerichtet
glaubst du dass diese ungleichheiten
eines tages behoben sein werden was
könnte ein politiker dazu bewegen die
kinder verschlingen saturn auf diät zu
setzen wie hast du das risiko einer
solchen demografischen spirale in deinem
land ein und wie würdest du ihr
entkommen wenn du ein melanie l in
spanien wer ist wie immer sind eure
meinung zu diesem thema schon gespannt
ich hoffe also dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat was ja gibt uns mit einem
like teil des neuen freundin vergesst
nicht dass ab mit blockieren keines
unserer videos nicht verpassen und
unterstützt unsere arbeit wird auch mit
einer kleinen spende über den link in
der beschreibung unter diesem video
macht gut und bis bald
[Musik]